mme affaires culturelles pour faire
plaisir à pierre arditi à londres il ya
une exposition de mort de bave de pub et
c'est merveilleux ce que vous faites est
là bien difficile vous iriez si vous
aimez l'art contemporain le quotidien
britannique 'the independent' vous
conseille d'aller à londres voir cette
exposition magnifique
c'est que l'islam est absolument évident
aujourd'hui fête culturelle puisque j'ai
agi seul dans une désignation
intelligent donc si vous voulez ne pas
prendre complètement ridicule
l'invitation d'ailleurs dans ses comptes
1 caisse et à la souris liam gallagher
souilem dugarry c'est bien la williams
gary locke est là sous il y à une
galerie vous avez une jeune femme qui
s'appelle laura godfrey isaac qui
trouvent qu'il faut parler un peu plus
souvent de ces matières de ces
substances plus ou moins corporels que
sont le pue
non mais c'est des tableaux ces sont des
tableaux alors séjour de tableau six
mille jours elle je vous ai dit c'est
pour vous donc ce sont des tableaux
alors autre chose
autre chose est ce que vous savez
pourquoi l'équipe nationale de côte
d'ivoire de basketball féminin a perdu
le championnat d'afrique
elle avait une telle exposition
pourquoi je vais vous dire c'est
l'explication du coup il est au pouvoir
il ya notre temps la contre performance
pour être fou
merde comment tu vas me lâche mais
nerveux la cei alors on y va
complètement piège
chaque organe remette les bat on ne
regarde pas aucun des trois allez on y
va et on y va parce qu'elle va compter
allez on attend alors je vous donne la
réponse des deux mètres voire ya le
temps la contre performance sportive
pour être être des 3 commence